in a poor neighborhood in the ecuadorian
capital quito rescue workers search for
bodies in the mud
17 hours of continuous torrential rain
overwhelmed a nearby reservoir on monday
sending a wall of water mud and rocks
through this residential area
franz hernandez is a migrant from
venezuela who works in quito
he was badly injured and his home was
destroyed
we were so scared we were in the living
room and we tried to leave the house but
it was too late a wave of flood water
burst through the front door it was so
powerful it broke the drawing too
oh my god
this footage was filmed by a woman
living there it shows a kilometer long
deluge of muddy water sweeping down her
street
dozens of people were killed and injured
authorities say the area is still unsafe
many things can still happen at the top
side of the mountain landslides can
still happen we're continuing to monitor
the situation with drones to provide
residents with a sense of safety and
calm
the mayor has set up shelters for
families forced to leave their homes but
many say the disaster could have been
prevented if the ravines bordering their
neighborhoods had been properly
maintained
this is not new it has been going on for
a long time we've sent many letters to
the municipality warning them about the
danger of the ravine this tragedy was
anticipated
many say they feared they wouldn't
survive the mudslide now those with the
least will have to rebuild what little
they had to start with
victoria gatenby al jazeera